did i actually
take your vote
to uh for the agreement a general item
between parliamentary i don't know
whether i got that for if not i'll
propose it have a second
[Music]
[Music]
just cancel the offers
okay item seven to consider
correspondence or any other business
especially brought forward by the
direction of chair
i've got any person
it's
of course she's just correcting me on my
manners can i say it's very very nice to
see council reach back in the building
in real time this time
hold on johnny welcome back
absolutely
item i don't need to answer questions
submitted under procedural rule a9
so there was one question submitted by
council of pentagon
and the answer is the answer has been
tabled as required under the
constitution uh it comes from a penalty
it's clearly not here but there is a
written response which you've all got a
copy of
item nine consultation of the strategy
for domestic abuse support and safe
accommodation and devon
[Music]
[Music]
because the full consultation document
wasn't attached to the full council
report which was
which we were supposed to
and so what i will do um i've speculated
to members earlier today but i'll
give some further explanation
clarifications into the objectives that
the devon county council are looking to
achieve
um with the support of us so effectively
um the domestic abuse act 21 um received
ruler sent in 20
on on the 29th of april 2021
um which placed a duty on county
councils to support victims of domestic
abuse and their children by
commissioning services and or safe
accommodation
effectively county has been given
um a sum of money 1.4 million pounds to
help achieve this objective
um and torridge have been involved in
the partnership board meetings
and
assisting them
with this objective so
we need to respond to the consultation
document that's been submitted
the objective one is for victims and
their children who are fleeing domestic
abuse can access good quality safe
accommodation that is appropriate to
individual needs
um and county are proposing to increase
the units of safe accommodation
available in devon
and provides
specialist domestic abuse support for
victims housing temporary accommodation
to reduce the risk against them
the second objective is victims
experiencing domestic abuse who wish to
remain in their home can do so safely to
prevent them from becoming homeless or
their risk of domestic abuse escalating
um and county would like to focus
resources on preventing people having to
leave their homes
and providing support while they remain
in their current accommodation
[Music]
outcome free
victims get the support they need to
leave an abusive relationship
and they want to be able to provide
specialist support to victims
with protective characteristics and or
complex needs
outcome for a range of torah informed
therapeutic support is available to
victims and their children to support
recovery and break the domestic abuse
cycle
um and county want to ensure that that
support is available to all at all
stages
whether they're children or adults
outcome five victims have appropriate
support to live safely free from abuse
um and they're seeking to provide
tailored support
to enable people to remain in their own
accommodation and continue to remain
independent going forward
outcome six uh receive
victims receive a person-centered
response that is tailored to their own
wants and needs again um
helping people to find the right
solution to suit their own personal
outcomes
um outcome seven services are domestic
abuse informed and work collectively to
support their victims and family so they
want to raise awareness of domestic
abuse and
impact on trauma and work with all
different uh services
and then devon county council and the
local partnership board have access to
consistent up-to-date data and the lived
experiences of victims um so they want
to do
that with feedback from
councils like ourselves when we assist
in
um
housing people who have been victims of
domestic abuse
um so like i say um this is a
consultation response whether we want to
support those objectives um and whether
we want to continue our involvement on
the devon domestic abuse partnership
board
happy to take any questions
thank you station
so there are three uh five one two and
five point three those are the
recommendations that you're referring to
and the last one that members support
the involvement of torture council with
the devon domestic abuse partnership
board and will seek to cooperate going
forward
to ensure that effective domestic abuse
support services relevant to this new
duty are delivered locally well i think
that can only be a good thing personally
too there's a recommendation here i'll
move her second did my nut cheddar
flavor
sorry yes yes
um
page 15 2.4 says members should note
that youtube involves a broad definition
of safe accommodation when you're due to
provide support however it does not
include temporary accommodations such as
bed and breaks and hotels can we be
assured there's enough accommodation for
people who are suffering domestic abuse
to be housed
or what happens to them if we haven't
got enough
is a
this is a county initiative so we'll
still support support them with what
what they're looking to do is give them
permanent solutions going forward rather
than place them in bed and breakfast it
doesn't override torridge's duty for
homelessness as a whole this is directly
for domestic abuse victims and trying to
give them the stability they need going
forward and not put them in temporary
accommodation there's no there's not
enough accommodation through the chair
not an accommodation sign we still put
them in
bed and breakfast until such time as
county of another accommodation
it's not necessarily county providing
the accommodation
and we put them in temporary
accommodation when we have to but not
specifically domestic abuse victims so
we'll still cover our full housing duty
if necessary so county
it's a new initiative
a lot of it still needs to be rolled out
they've given 1.4
million towards assisting um obviously
we've had discussions over homelessness
and
housing so it's not you know it's not a
um we're not going to solve the problem
overnight but what they're effectively
saying is they don't want to put these
victims into temporary accommodation
they want to give them the penance they
need to be able to thrive um going
forward yeah i i accept that through
here but at this time
from what i'm picturing here that they
do not have accommodations that counting
and should people and there will be
suffering abuse where do they go do we
still put them in temporary
accommodation until such time as county
have
uh accommodation i hear you saying
stated that i can't quite put the two
together because
yeah in the future there'll be
accommodation at the moment there isn't
so what happens to people now
i can't commit to finishing it you know
answer to that
we do our best
um you know people do have to go to
temporary accommodation until we can
find someone else's voice yeah
somewhere
because this implies that we're not
looking at that side and pushing it
across the county even though it says
yeah this is more in relation to
domestic abuse as opposed to a housing
strategy well yeah but i mean
victims
they still need some way to go don't
they get away from what they have there
that's all
special another
yeah thank you chuck i've only briefly
looked through this
seven county council consultation
documents
interesting
reading here
and actually north governor torridge
cancelled the fairing quite well
actually i'm not saying with perfect i'm
not saying that
but we are headed again but when you
look at devon as a whole compared to
cornwall plymouth tour bay and kent
41 dead spaces are all that we can offer
i mean it's it's criminal
that that in the area of government
eight hundred and two thousand
people living in denver that's all we
can offer but if not again we do have
27 of the 42 dead spaces in a
purpose-built building in north devon
and we also run which is quite unique a
sanctuary scheme which is being operated
where victims remain in their own homes
and we had a presentation
that
overview and script next turn
and that was made by well i made it and
several other counselors
it's dreadful that
principally women mothers using children
they take note of their things
perpetrator remains there so this
sanctuary scheme is a reverse of that
where the perpetrator is out in and the
parent and the mother normally and
children remain in their own home enough
that to me is
critical importance there's not enough
being done in devon as a whole but at
least in north denman torridge we are
well on to
into addressing it but i do urge all
councillors do look at this
consultation document a lot of
interesting information
thank you castle
okay anyone else wish to speak we've
been proposed been seconded
joel found for all in favor of
supporting that
thank you
okay item 10 on the agenda's
safeguarding policy which is pages 18 to
31.
i'm going to leave stacy open to present
this
[Music]
duty to ensure that we have arrangements
in place to discharge our safeguarding
responsibilities
um our last safeguarding policy was
updated in 2016. we did have a joint um
safeguarding policy at that stage with
the other development authorities but it
seems that the others have have tended
to draft their own since that point so
uh
ours was due for a review and a revamp
too so i've attached the draft [ __ ] um
at pages 22 onwards um effectively and
making it clear that safeguarding is
everyone's responsibility
um and ensuring that our other policies
also take safeguarding into account
so um our disciplinary procedure
grievance procedures equality policy etc
and i also just wanted to clarify to
people that
data protection shouldn't be a bar to
disclosing a safeguarding concern um if
we have a safeguarding concern and the
last thing that we should do is not
disclose because of the data protection
act and in fact we have a duty to do so
so if anyone's ever got any queries in
relation to that um then please feel
free to to come to me and have a chat
um and then i've attached the
flowchart at the back which makes it
clear
what should be done and when and the
officers who are responsible for
safeguarding within torridge and once
again happy to take any any questions
anyone wish to ask a question
[Music]
ah that looks like that's pretty
unanimous what is there any against
iron abstentions
[Music]
item 11 is the annual report on treasury
management for 2021 which is pages 32-37
and david hayes is going to present this
report
thank you
and the council adopted the central code
of practice for treasury management
in the public sector which requires me
to report to you as a council on our
treasury management activity for the
previous financial year
and so apologies for the report it is
somewhat dry technical and a little bit
dull in nature for being perfectly
honest but i thought maybe nothing go
through line by line i've just got in
some of the key highlights from the
treasury management
activity for the year that's gone
the cost of our financing as a council
has actually gone up that mainly well
it's exclusively because
our income has dropped from the money
that we get from short-term treasury
management deposit simply because the
interest rates declined and were cut by
the chancellor in response to the colbit
pandemic
we didn't undertake any new borrowing
during the financial year that's gone
2020-21
we actually paid down 153 000 pounds of
what's called public works long board
during debt during 2020 21. just for
people who have it public works loan
board that's historic debt that the
council had with three days this housing
stock transfer so that's
debt that the council probably took out
over 20 years ago now and slowly over
time it's withering on the van as we've
repaid it i mean
without any new problem in four years
time the council would be debt-free um
also we've been there
there's a lot of um in the prudential
indicators indicators about how we're
funding our capital now we're borrowing
prudently essentially
well all the capital that we funded in
the financial year 2020-21 was actually
funded either from grants
from
reserves which were revenue
contributions that we previously made
from our revenue budgets or from capital
receipts so we didn't actually fund any
um of our capital expenditures from
borrowing and we certainly didn't borrow
to support our revenue budgets during
the year and our cash flow remains
healthy happy to take any questions uh
and the report has just been noted
any questions david
can i just
to be honest i would have to go through
minutes of 20 years ago and we've done
to actually detail the information as to
what originated those long but it
probably would have been capital works
that were undertaken probably 17 to 20
years ago because the environment
generally have a 25 or 30 years old
within four years time we would have
paid them all off
the debt the probably works long boards
i think it was a lot higher by the point
of the stock transfer but the majority
of our debt at that point related to
loans that we've taken out for our
housing stock
[Music]
i think it's
2027 2027
is actually 26 is the last year that
we'll have any public work loan debt
this council however you have authorized
officers to borrow new debt for the
environmental sensor
and should the um
levine upfront application variety the
hardware successfully progressed with
that project we've also got a facility
to borrow again so what i'm saying is in
four years time our historic legacy debt
will be repaid
but we've probably hopefully before
hopefully before then we'll take out new
debt because that'll mean that we've
actually got an environment sensor
thank you
thank you for that report i think we
need to take a vote on that
just for nothing sorry answer it all did
you
have a question
[Music]
[Music]
that is actually up to us but we've
actually modeled everything over 20. but
it can be termed at a later juncture but
we've modeled everything over 20 years
most of us will be around to see that so
here we go
yes
the reason i'm asking is that you're
probably aware that there's a big move
now to get devon county to disinvest
with fossil fuels in his pension fund
and i think devon county they operate
our pension fund as well don't they we
pledge to us
is it now the time for us to start
looking at this and saying to devon
county
why are you still investing in fossil
fuels because we've actually declared a
climate emergency on torres and so is
devon county and it is bizarre that they
still have investment and i was just
doing some research today and i see all
sorts of accounting councils actually um
managed to disinvest
if one county can do it i wonder if we
shouldn't as a district go to the county
and say isn't it about time you started
trying to do that i mean sorry just i
mean it's a little bit because of the
pandemic you go to the last
employers meeting so i don't think
things are necessary isn't quite as
clear-cut so one of the
uh
reasons
is
that
example of shell everybody would assume
that shell they're a fossil fuel
company
they're actually the biggest investors
renewable energy
um in europe
so there's two sides as they're trying
to disinvest themselves from fossil
fuels so they made a presentation on
that saying that they aren't aware and
they've got to within their
investment portfolio they've got an
aspired aspiration to be green now this
is 18 months ago so i'm not banged up
today on what they're doing at the
moment and then i think the next
employers events
will probably be in february
where one can ask questions but if you
want me to feed any questions in the
meantime please do but obviously we're
one of i think 300 members of the
pension fund
so you know so the caveat would be
what influence we would have
individually we are one of 300 members
of that pension fund
thank you for that i suspect you're
going to hear a lot more about okay
yes guys
i receive a pension
[Music]
emergency uh working group and uh
as we pointed out that
the scheme that the county subscribes to
does actually offer an alternative
policy i think
not too sure that shell is such a
marvelous example i
county council when they paid the
presentation that they told me and the
members there that shell were the
biggest investors in renewable energy
in i think
thank you mr chairman i'll declare it
within your interest
pension fund
as far as i'm concerned i'd like them to
invest at the best return they can get
i'm not getting carried away with ponzi
schemes you're here
okay
um
ryan we don't need a vote on that it's
merely for receiving so we'll move on to
item 12
brunswick dwarf land release fund which
is pages 38 to 46
and
sean carney i believe is going to
report thank you chair uh so the purpose
of the report in front of you is to
inform you of the details of the land
release fund uh award that was made
storage for the keyword works of
brunswick wharf and to seek your
approval that that award some be added
to the capital program so the report
talks about history of the site which
you'll obviously be very familiar with
and gives a bit of a chronology as to
how we've got to where we are it gives
details of the consented scheme and its
component elements
as well as talking about the current
status of ownership of the site from the
contract
there's talk of the one public estate
scheme and its intention and the land
release fund which is intended to assist
small schemes with liability issues and
that's the one we applied to
it draws conclusions all of which lead
us to the recommendation and the
recommendation is that we add the award
some 797.000
[Music]
i did ask some time ago
when we heard about this grant which is
basically
a gift to the developer because
when we were on the planning committee
when we had it before us
it was built into his viability study
that he would do this
and now the government's going to pay
800 000 pounds for it i did ask at the
time had the officers go on to talk to
the development to see what he might
offer us now in kind of quid pro quo and
i was told that those talks were ongoing
can i ask what the result of that has
been
so the the result is no change to the
contracted scheme
uh the consent is scene sorry
the basically the grant award has been
made on the basis that the scheme is
unviable
even with the uh award some the scheme
remains unviable
and in planning actually it was
referenced the grant award was
referenced
in the viability for planning purposes
so there was that was taken into account
then
brenton before i ask a question on my
own
thank you
uh
well first of all i'd like to practice
finally i have to say uh with two items
uh
first i'm surprised i wasn't only
mentioned tonight that the
legal proceedings against
a previous
developer on this site
haven't progressed was deemed to be not
in the public interest
so after a massive file i gave to
torridge four years ago
plus
an investigation which has continued up
to about
four months ago
um no action is being taken so the
message is clear isn't it crime does pay
there we go and the second point i want
to make is that
to my
certain knowledge that no current
officers and co-op officers alone had
any involvement with that
debacle that took place
back previous to 2016.
in the report that uh shawn was
presented to us tonight
at the year 2016 it says developers
withdrew due to viability issues
that is not true
simply not true
the developer was
basically sacked by torridge because
they he failed to meet the criteria plus
the fact as i mentioned before torridge
was dealing with a company oceanside
that didn't actually exist
it was quite a quite serious
administration
further down
it says that
in march 2025 read our secure fault and
consent
becomes unconditional
but it's not
i've looked at the heads of terms and i
had a struggle to get that i was
in a legal world
you know i didn't have to ask three
times before i eventually
uh was allowed to look at them and i did
look at them there were masses of them
but that really interested me at the
time was
the state of the world
because after all we're going to inherit
that
and the comprehensive
structural report on that wall and what
needed to be done and it is
expensive and there is a lot to do
but this seems to have been watered down
somehow in the report because further on
it goes on to talk about
uh on the contract of
that um
that there are no
no conditions attached
but
that simply is not the case
they signed up to these heads of terms
so they've got to follow
what was stated in those sensitives and
i for one will be keeping a close eye to
ensure that they do because we are going
to inherited that means future taxpayers
in this area will have to bear the brunt
of the cost of any future repair work
that needs to be done on there
plus the fact i've asked a series of
questions
uh and the head of legal revenues i've
had no response from that and no reply
to do with the legal status for example
of the walkway and the wall
amongst others
and i think also a member of the public
has asked questions as well which has
been no reply
so there are some
actual holes in this report
and i think as a council we want to be
really wary about this and i suppose the
final thing was really
i mean a lot about the scope of this
thing upset me as you well know because
i hang on about it time and time again
like a worn record really but like you
know i'm sorry but you know i'm a bit of
a person
i'm a counselor supposed to represent
people that's supposed to be looking
after the interest of the taxpayer as
apart from the community and then i've
seen the in the gazette last week's
gazette
we see that the developer is going to
support financially support um
the charity enterprise women first it's
called sports women are rough sleeping
sofa serving doing in temporary
accommodation
dammit we've just given away for a
hundred thousand pounds and is a
giveaway to a developer a vast piece of
land which could have been used for
housing for our people as it was forever
when brent close we've just lost that
and yet this developer and the kindness
of heart is going to support our
big bloody
[Music]
deal thank you councilman for that
contribution
um i've got a question for you sean you
mentioned just know
viability did i hear you correct
um
what was the viability issue you
referred to
to do with the current radar development
without without this 797 thousand are
you saying that the scheme or are they
saying that the scheme would not have
been viable for them would not have
proceeded
yet so so in in planning terms to be
policy compliant
the scheme with or without the ground is
unviable
well that's a question let's just ask
yes so if if we didn't get the 797 000
pounds the scheme would not go ahead
but i can't i can't speak well if it was
not viable
well
as far as i'm aware redheart's intention
is to develop headscheme so they they
they're intending to do that
what's been recognized by the land
release fund is that the scheme doesn't
meet the viability threshold and they're
prepared to invest 797 thousand pounds
from the land release funds
into it to expedite the delivery and
ensure that they're very positive so
that's the purpose was the land release
scheme that are saying the scheme would
be unviable without their
um contribution that's right they've
accepted that okay thank you
that's going to bring you want to come
back home
when you talk about viability i assume
you mean
that the company
needs to make a profit and that's
written into what they call viability am
i correct that's creative it's a 20
million pound scheme they would expect
to make a million and a half two million
profit okay they're not doing it for a
charity you're not charity do it for
profit so
yes that's correct uh there is a
profit is allowable in a viability
assessment i can't tell you off the top
of my head what profit element was in
this vibrancy system
okay thank you
uh casey christine
yeah i should just make rather
bizarre point really um
i was reading through the the british
trust minutes for 60 years ago as i do
and uh the british trust sold the piece
of grass
which is
at the end of the bridge which obviously
is very important to this part of this
scheme because we want a walkway from
the bridge crosstalk
when it was sold to brand hotels
and i've read it in our minutes uh
brenda hotel is actually responsible for
the river war at the end of their bit
which might save torres quite a lot of
money actually um
i'd like our solicitor to look into that
i'll figure out the minutes i haven't
got the original sale document but uh
that was written into our minutes that
would be the agreement because up until
then the british trusts were
responsible
and can i just add one other thing we're
responsible we're going to take on the
river wall without seven meters
of car
it's great yeah i know it's been said
before but
if we are in charge of it we can put a
cycle path in this camera can't we
it would be our land thank you
mackenzie
uh i'd like to propose that we accept
the recommendation
yeah and
it's been proposed by council mackenzie
second of my council and knew him that
we accept the recommendations as listed
and i'm sure guys are all in favor
and against
extensions
two abstentions
okay item 13 on your agenda it's the
appointment of cancers to the local
authority trading company board which is
pages 4748
council holston did you wish to speak
before
um stacy does her reporter after
well the the reporter i'm sorry
um the report actually asks for
nominations
um
for a fourth member
for the board
and i have gotten home
for a nomination to
fill that board
position but if you want me to wait
until stasis spoke through it
or i'll throw it out there now and
people can ponder
before stacy's speaking you do it on
your feet
right i'm on my feet um i have spoken to
the counselor involved
um to make sure that they were happy
with my proposal
i would like to
wholeheartedly endorse a proposal for
councillor shirley langford to take that
fourth
place on the board
[Music]
i think she offers
a skill set
uh that will
only benefit the board
and a great enthusiasm
and dedication to
um recreation sport etc
so
i'm sure she will be a real asset for us
thank you thank you country are there
any other nominations
mr brian
sorry
i'd like to propose although he isn't
here tonight councillor john hutchins
this role i think we need to have a
business focused approach and as a
businessman i think that he will add
something to this board and help drive
this forward so i look for a second
appearance
okay so do you have a second
[Music]
has been proposed and seconded the show
of answers
are we are we having any discussion on
this before we actually vote on the
individual i thought somebody's going to
speak to it well this is purely for the
member to be actually on the board it
will be a special
report afterwards unless you feel it's
appropriate to have a report first
if
if i could just if i could just speak
then to the nominations part very
briefly i'd like to reinforce the fact
that the focus of this board has got to
be a hard business focus
[Music]
whatever we think of it
this this activity this discretionary
activity
which by my estimation is used by less
than two percent
of the population of our district
we have got to
keep hold of the costs
and indeed as a council i would imagine
that we will be laying upon that board
to drive down the costs to the taxpayer
in time and i noticed councillor
pennington made reference to it in uh
in the note that he sent rounds
and therefore i am not opposing
the nominations as such but i would just
like to reinforce that the most the
overarching function of this board is
business
um and it must be
and this council and i would be
keen to say that we
will not fund a bottomless pit with
overrun and overrun there will be a line
in the sand and there will be a time
when there's a majority here that says
stop
because the amount of money ladies and
gentlemen
is grossly disproportionate within our
budget it's huge
and the budget is getting tighter
so all i'd say is just keep our eye very
firmly that this must be a business
focused board that doesn't stop subject
matter expert been
coming to it to enrich the decisions of
the board but um
business first please
thank you councilman that's a very
important point you've made and you've
made it very well but clearly
i agree with you there needs to be
a wide mixture of talent on
on that board and hopefully with what's
being proposed we'll get a good mixture
of exactly that did someone else ever
had her counselor
not expecting nothing less from cancer
to say you know costs etc is all
important
no it isn't
we're providing a service that's what
it's about all right it's only two
percent use it wait a minute i question
that figure we actually are swimming
pools we get our children to learn to
swim
how many people drown every year because
they can't swim we've always had that
tradition of teaching our youngsters how
to swim you can't do this
i can remember when the proposals were
holes where they came forward for a
swimming pool
there was a lot of opposition on this
that council then but we supported it in
biddeford because we recognized the
wider services that it provided yes of
course cost importantly run away with
the money you know
willy-nilly i mean they're going to look
at a much more uh professional way than
the previous incumbents did that's for
sure because we as councillors will be
keeping an eye on it
so we will be making sure that there
isn't any uh untoward stuff going on so
no problem there but at the end of the
day we are about a service that's why
we're here as councillors our parks
produce no money
lots of things this council provide have
no financial reward in them so you know
if we're not here for service what the
hell are we doing here
to a
degree uh look at this leisure
provision
it's never gonna
would be lucky for everybody it's not
gonna break we know
but i do accept that we've got to keep
on the board this board of this
uh arms then to come they'll have to
keep their
eye very closely on those costs but this
council will always have to such about
that
the key appointment for me is the
non-executive director that's the key
member of this board whoever that person
turns it that is the key for me the key
appointment
okay
sorry can i just answer a point of
clarification and on the recommendations
um it's got aid to appoint a member to
serve on the labc4
act to fight um
survival and providing the right service
and you provide the right service in
part by having people know what the
right service is and if you look at the
private ones we know in the area or
certainly i know the person may not be
well she wants a very good business but
she provides what the community wants
and that is the way you will get
successful business is providing the
right service
and the fact that members of the board
i'm not going to say that financial
because i probably back the level that
we need and that will come out from the
non-executive member
that we're
hopefully going to
appoint um i don't think we've
made a public announcement yet so i
won't go any farther on that but i can
assure you it will be a business-minded
person and i hope the rest of us will be
but the success of this enterprise
relies on people using it and the way to
get people to use it is to provide the
service they want
and that's what has to be a joint
exercise people will come if we provide
the right service and that will boost
the economic side we can run it as
tightly as we like but if people don't
come to it we're not going to get
anywhere so there is a balance to the
phone i hope we would do it somebody
said to me you know the possibly that
the person we were looking at may well
say if we're not doing a good enough job
don't walk away and i said
if we're not doing a good enough job i
will walk away and let somebody else do
it it is really important for this
council we succeed we see cornwall you
know looking at shutting some swimming
pools
it could be really difficult to even get
near to balance in it
but we have a step we have a
discretionary
role in this to allow people
um as um consequently say my children
one of them learn from children one of
them learns in lordstrom um and they can
both swim have a lot better than i can
so if it ever comes from a push i would
hope they will save me because i don't
necessarily say that
so
i think we're getting the balance right
and so on the recommendations i would
like to recommend it i will recommend
shirley langford coaster lampwood is the
member to serve on the board and the
shadow board which we've already had two
meetings actually represented by
councillor podson from northern
coast uh coastal wright from
uh torrington and councillor hutchins
from holdsworthy so they're serving on
the shadow board which will see us
through to the next spring
when the board itself actually takes
complete control
from 1610 and i don't think we can make
well i'm not going to say that we can't
make it worse than they are because
that's tempting
i'd just like to support the
recommendations and move on thank you
thank you i've got two
three speakers i'm cursing newton okay
it's a couple of content
hopefully you'll be the last one there
then we'll take it a little bit
chad just to come back on what's been
said because uh quite a few of the
comments are related to my opening
statement
to be business focused
of course includes the whole viability
otherwise it wouldn't be i mean the
business is wider than just
the economics but by using it and being
popular
and being good quality
therefore the costs to us hopefully come
down because more people are using it
and therefore generating more income
that is a business case of it so of
course it involves everybody but it's
all part of the business case um so i'm
not just talking about money i'm talking
about the whole thing that will make it
sustainable and viable sustainable
within our budget
[Music]
and being fit and healthy and active i
think that's the overarching aim not
about money it's about the combination
of everything and getting everyone using
it so i was yeah i was quite
disappointed to hear councilman newton's
opening
um
every time this council talks about
finances council brenton stands up and
says we have to give residents value the
money
here he is
scoffing at what counts and newton is
saying
saying we should be keeping a tight
rating on costs
i don't see the problem with that we can
still give the public what they want to
a degree we don't have a bottomless pit
and sometimes as has been said tonight
when you look at leisure centers they
can be a bottomless pit they don't
provide
funds they don't provide profits of any
sort
we are prepared i believe
to uh to absorb some of that but there
comes a time when you say enough is
enough so you know if council brenton is
advocating spends ben spent no i did
well you just demanded what i did
the residents will come back to see you
about that i'm sure thank you thank you
right it's been proposed and seconded
langford
is uh
director and it's actually really
exciting to look forward to so i don't
know why we've got all of this
negativity
thank you
right i'm not going to be interrupted
again let's have the the vote please
for council langford to be
a member of to serve on the latc board
so it's been proposed and seconded
all in favor of currency
any
obsessions okay thank you that's carrie
and i take it b we've already done b
have we
okay councillor james has proposed the
uh the members for holes within orbit
oregon would you like to just remind me
who they were it was councillor hutchins
with him yeah
yeah for the shadow board yeah um
represents all them yeah
almost thank you
was there anyone against i don't
understand thank you
all right stay tuned
you have to do anything
that's all done
uh petitions there are no petitions so
we read on item 15 those are motion we
have two
um
one is from councillor haynes defensive
level which occurred in the order of the
seat on the agenda
so
[Music]
already
um
members should be now aware that there's
been a massive decline in biodiversity
in the uk over the last 50 years the
latest authoritative state of the nation
report
records that since the 1970s 41
of all uk species
have decreased
with 15 of species threatened with
extinction
regarding particular species the report
reported for example uk bringing third
houses fell by 44 million between 1967
and 2009
and that numbers of habitat specific
butterflies fell by 68
between 1976 and 2018
at torridge we have approved the climate
and biodiversity plan which commits to
conserve and increase biodiversity and
recently a recommendation was approved
to support north denver biosphere's
nature recovery
nationally all public bodies have a
statutory duty of the natural
environment of world communities
[Music]
and the government and other public
bodies are committed to implementing the
uk biodiversity action plan
to enable transforming these commitments
i suggest that there is a strong need
for this council to employ a bible
but i suggest that the officer's primary
roles should be drafted encouraged by
diversity
to report to council achievement of
targets in the plan
to provide expert input into the current
local planning review in order to
strengthen biodiversity policies and to
fully assess the wildlife value of the
proposed participated
designated development sites
to assess planning applications
regarding wildlife aspects of proposed
development sites and the ecological
reports submitted by applicants
one aim will be to reduce the need to
mitigate and offset the process which
fails to properly replace the loss of
biodiversity on development sites
however when litigation and offsetting
are required the vital role of knoxville
will be to monitor
implementation over a number of years
function
further
objective
arsenal would be to represent council on
banning appeals
to advise councillors and officers about
all aspects of wildland conservation
including relevant regulations and
legislation revised on ways of
concerning enhancement
spaces any tdc buildings which are
important habitats any ssis and wildlife
sites under the college's control and
the biodiversity implications related to
council's procurement policy
to create and maintain a wildlife
database encourages open spaces and
other wildlife sites and torridge to
communicate and ensure knowledge among
small town forage departments of all
aspects of the council's role in
concerning and promoting biodiversity
and how this relates to officer
decisions to liaise with wildlife groups
local farmers local authorities
government agencies and other bodies to
promote education and awareness about
wildlife and the environment of the
forage area and to encourage individual
and community initiatives to conserve
and increase biodiversity
ideally the officer will be a full time
but
otherwise it would be full-time but
otherwise part-time or shared with the
navigator authority for example
another option could be for the council
to retain a consultant but i suggest
this is not a very satisfactory
alternative
in conclusion i urge members to take the
decline of biodiversity very seriously
indeed and to recognize this council's
commitments and vital role in helping to
arrest this decline and to contribute to
restorations cases and habitats
thank you
point of order chad
thanks question
um my understanding in this council chap
is that the appointment of officers
below the level of senior management
team is the responsibility of the chief
executive and is not the business of
members
that is my understanding as well but
nevertheless it was emotionally
well you can certainly suggest that and
you certainly have yeah
we can't do anything more if what i'm
saying
far
seriously going to look at this
okay just before we go
yeah
cnn
because
it's been very clear since we lost our
tree officer that we've lost a lot of
expertise
i know we go out to outside bodies and
ask but it's not quite the same
and
the problem i think that i'm talking now
as a member of the planning committee
is that
currently
developers
commission
the ecology report
and you have to ask how objective
are these reports
because we had a classic instance and
i'm sure the members of the planning
committee will recall it uh haywood road
this is the road between morrisons and
biblica behaviour road rounder there was
a big development by the roadside there
250 houses councillor watson nearly got
killed uh we all remember that on the
site visit
we all remember that and we had an
ecologist report we said it was
basically sterile there's nothing there
it wasn't worth deserving
the opponents commissioned another
report which said it was actually full
of reptiles full of really worthwhile
stuff and you have to ask
where was the
uh
if you like the
solomon
in a thing like that who would actually
tell us give us objective robots
that's what we need
and this is why i think we do need this
officer and i hope the uh chief
executive
will take this on board
because
currently
we get plan we sit there we hear the
plans we had a classic one just recently
i've already referred to it once
it was encountered laws
area i think um a development at
tadworthy road where it was they just
said oh there's a couple of ponds and
some hedgerows that had to come out
these are really important
and yet they were just dismissed and
nobody really picked up on that this is
where an ecology officer would actually
really help
i think if we could share we already
share one opportunity
the climate change officer i think we
might better share another one because
we've got it we've got to rewrite our
local plan and with all the
current interests in biodiversity and so
on i think this is going to loom large
in that local plan we do need an officer
to help us actually come up with our
policies
thank you christie i i don't disagree
with the sentiment
you've just uh spoken about but um
am i right am i right you're thinking no
then that the the appointment can only
be made by the chief executive all we
can really do is to make a
recommendation to him
so would you like to make that
recommendation council haynes to the
chief executive to look seriously at any
future staffing
uh reshuffle what you like that we look
at potentially engaging an officer at
this time because we don't have the
power to actually tell him
okay
well i actually i support president on
this
i think that
it is up to elected members
to
put forward
the perceived need for whatever the
office might be
and once i accepted the chief exec to
actually appoint
nothing to stop elected members from
putting forward and i think the right
place to send it is to see an arm where
we can then have a proper report on it
and we can hear the views of the chief
etc
possible opportunity
so as part of the um
the point that council has made i think
there's going to be a significant
investigation
it would need to be done
with service managers in planning
underground maintenance on our estates
team uh with north devon council whose
suggestion we might share an officer so
there's a significant amount of
background work that we would need to do
what we're also specifying here is
probably a service we don't currently
provide so what council haynes is
proposing is stepping up
our provision of ecology assessment and
stepping up our provision of
the work associated with that so i think
it to rush something to cnr is probably
hasting um i think the chief executive
would be the right person to make that
assessment for you how that's reported
back i'm not quite sure the mechanism
but
i think
yeah there's a lot of background work
yeah okay so i think what we need to do
here then is clearly there is going to
be
a lot of work done on
future officers as you
identify but clearly as councilor hayes
said and
that's the question made the point i
think we're all of the opinion now that
you know the environment you know it is
a real big issue you know nationally
it's a big issue uh and certainly it is
and certainly on tourist so
i don't we're too far away we're
probably employing an officer of that
type to you know to look after
torridge's interests
on our behalf but
it's not an oral brief to actually say
that now all we can really do is make a
recommendation we can ask the chief
executive at the earliest possible
opportunity to seriously consider
the point that councilman
would that be the way to go
but we can't order him to employ once
certainly away
well apparently cnr is not the place at
this moment
so it could be debated
which can't be
suggested that it could be at some point
in the future but clearly you know it
shouldn't be lost and i'm sure that
council haynes won't allow it to be lost
anyway
so can we leave it like that
right
okay we've had a proposal and we've got
a second
potentially christie that
along the lines that council haines has
indicated she's been proposing second
that we get that to the vote risk
or that we employ an officer
in the way that comes with
the suggestion
that wasn't i understood i thought that
the proposal was to go to cnr
no cnr wasn't mentioned
in his motion
it was that we
sorry
did you want to measure the motion to
clear a recommendation to the juicer
dark in for a
[Music]
having no minute
no information on a whim of one person
you know there are wider implications
here after what president christie said
you know
is he implying then every planning
application that comes in from here on
in if we appoint said expert
um
then won't have an independent ecology
assessment we'll get our people on it
you know there's a whole
raft of um unanswered questions here and
to just plow right in and get us all to
vote on something that actually we've
got no information about yeah
well you can you can vote cancer we can
vote yes or
no we're setting what this council needs
in terms of staff
and for me it will be the planning
manager or that department will put a
request to senior management but the
need for the work that needs doing at
the moment once we start appointing
staff at these meetings yeah
everybody's going to come along wanting
an appointment
and we can't do it it's simply not
um miserable i understand exactly where
you're coming from but nevertheless
we've had a notice of motion and it's
been seconded so we've got to take it
all
[Music]
so better
okay so because it's changing his nose
emotions so that it goes to the chief
executive for consideration at a future
date
okay
[Music]
apparently
[Music]
right so it's been proposed by
councillor payne seconded by professor
um
this is referred to the chief executive
for consideration at a future date
all in favor of that please
come back oh no
well if necessary the chief of jet will
come back with an announcer
well we'll have to wait and see where
the tube attack comes back with
getting lucky
okay it's been proposed and seconded
anyone wish to
uh show concern support then please
raise your hands
and against
uh abstentions
no okay that's clearly that lotion
okay the next nose of motion is uh
cursor leather
and you're meant to have three minutes
or 90 90 words but that's already gone
out of the window so thank you for it
thank you chair thank you
um well this this
came to my attention that
the rspca are running a nationwide
campaign though
um
to ban
as it says in the notice of motion
live animals being given us prizes
um
there's a crack made this morning to me
this morning about saving gold
it's not just to do with goldfish but
that's
that's the gist of it you obviously now
i'm not sure it happens on the
fairground
when it comes to dinner and i don't
think it's a big problem
generally in torrance but i think it's
nationwide campaign that the rspca
are
carrying out and i think
because we're all animal lovers
i know that for sure
i think this notice
could be voted on and carried through
and it will show that this council just
takes seriously the issue
of animals and it does happen it's not
just goldfish from fairgrounds in
plastic bags but throughout the country
some live animals don't even horses off
as prizes sometimes and this speaks to
the land that we've got control over
it's just been a tweak of our license
when anybody wanted to have an event in
the park or on any of our land that
they can't give live animals with
clients it's quite straightforward
and i won't be with this council because
it is full of animals
the support is not so much
um
the animal welfare app that was passed
in 2006
it refers to that in places where
it is illegal for
to transfer animals by way of sales
or as a prize to a person on the 16th
and and all that this goes to us is
confirmed that this council
do not support the giving of live
animals and prizes because all the
things that pull from that even a
goldfish giving us a prize
it's taken up people haven't got proper
facilities they stick it in a round ball
which isn't suitable but it's not just
about those it's about any animal so i'm
hoping somebody will second this and we
can have a
[Music]
i need to go to cnr um to approve
or to recommend
experiment no i know but apparently it
still has to go to cnr if we're going to
ban something uh on tauruses or central
land but we can certainly write to the
uk government urging an outright ban as
a full council
well i i i don't agree i think this
council can vote
yeah just to clarify so full council
can agree to write to the government
supporting the ban but cnr have control
over the council's london property so
without like ban on college land would
need to go to cnn for approval
it just means one more meeting
all in favor appreciate
thank you
okay item 16 and 17 this is where we
move into part two so kind of a
recommendation that we need
for mackenzie second in our second all
in favor moving to part two
thank you